what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john how's
everything going so good it's it's
insane insanity ladies and gentlemen we
are gonna watch from our good friend
paul heavy spoilers ant-man and the wasp
trailer breakdown today we have not seen
the trailer that was circulating online
i want to wait for the actual footage
before seeing it in motion but i'm i'm
just itching to hear something yeah i
want to know a little bit more yeah
absolutely even if i got some of the
information in my noggin now it's not
going to be like when we actually see
the trailer on display so yeah i wanted
to watch this subscribe to paul's
channel if you haven't done so already
he is almost at a million subscribers he
well deserves to be he's also a great
dude in real life trust me and talk to
him almost every single day yeah let's
get to it let's see what's going on
leave a like that won't take too much of
your time so please go ahead and do it
alrighty enough
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and i've always liked
that the ant-man movies show that no
matter what size you are you can still
get the girl it's something i relate to
a lot
and the little guy has made a big impact
in the mcu from what we saw at san diego
comic con ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania has the potential to be one of the
biggest or smallest movies in phase five
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down what happened in the
teaser i mean peyton reed did come out
and say that he thinks this will change
the mcu forever and you don't often hear
them say change the mcu forever you hear
it a little bit more often than you
expect i don't know we'll see the
hierarchy of power in the mcu is about
to change who toot kevin feige announced
at san diego comic con that this will be
the first film in the phase and we know
from the trailer league that it'll
introduce kang the conqueror he was of
course brought up by he who remains at
the end of loki and there's been a lot
of chatter online after the event about
how good jonathan mages is now what's
interesting about kang is that there's
so many different versions of him in the
marvel universe whether it's rama turt
immortus victor timely iron lad or
whoever you never know which version of
kang that you're gonna get there are an
infinite number of him across the
multiverse
and the ability to move throughout it
and therefore every time a character
runs into him it's a roll of the dice
now phase six will end with two avengers
movies in the same year both of which
will center around kang and his dynasty
so lots of things are going to be
happening in quantum mania that have big
repercussions and the first look gives
some jonathan major things away
people feel
or you've heard people talking about
what happens in it either way i just
want to go through a bit by bit and
break down everything about it quantum
mania will heavily feature kang and this
is going to be made clear from the off
according to people at the event he
narrates the new look from the beginning
and throughout it we hear him saying
you're an interesting man scott lang
you've lost a lot of time but time it's
not what you think it's not a straight
line when you can see time the way i do
you can see everything
which is everywhere
i i should have been cast as kang
anyway now this of course would have
been all right wouldn't it no
good american accent getting lost in the
quantum realm after the events of
ant-man and the wasp though to him it
only felt like a handful of hours the
real world has had five years go by and
because of this his daughter aged up
from a kid to a teen
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyway we know from the poster that
cassie lang will be returning for the
movie and though she's now played by
catherine newton she'll be a very big
part of the adventure i gotta say i feel
bad for the actress who has cast an end
game and is not returning for this to my
understanding i could be wrong about
this but to my understanding she was not
informed that she would not be returning
and instead just got you know replaced
that being said catherine newton is a
great great actress if you have not seen
oh my god what is it called the movie
with vince vaughn and the slasher oh oh
freaky she's great she's great the first
poster for the film shows her in a
purple suit and it's lucky that she'll
becoming the character stinger from the
comics she was also called stature at
one point but i think they'll probably
just jump straight to stinger as it fits
better with the book personas that the
rest of the squad have now from what my
uncle could make out watching the dodgy
clip on twitter there's a tiny blue
beacon that opens up in the lab and
cassie gets sucked into this along with
the rest of the characters oh it seems
that they're experimenting on the
quantum realm and whether cassie opens
this up accidentally or someone from
insider pulls them in remains to be seen
my guess is that they're all taken there
though including janet who will likely
help them to navigate the dimension this
can be slightly seen in the trailer and
janna ends up donning her hooded costume
that she had on in ant-man and the wasp
when hank was reunited with her we don't
know exactly what she got up to when she
was down there but it seems like she
found refuge in kang city which exists
in the dimension i just had a thought
i feel like to really sell the stakes
and uh that like this threat especially
if you know i don't know if ant-man's
going to win this time around or not i
have a feeling
hank pym is going to die he's definitely
going to die my feeling is hank who's
going to he's going to be into taking
that plunge so i don't know that's just
the theory that i have just watching
this footage it was like i really feel
like hank's gonna die in this one we'll
see and it seems to be the age that she
would have been on earth and we saw with
scott that the area he was in had time
moving differently so janet likely found
refuge for the 30 odd years she was down
there and just chilled out watching
heavy spoilers amazing videos
like in subway now according to the
people at the event there's a point in
it where we see the group all journeying
there and it's filled with humanoids
that have markings on their faces oh
cool there's also kang's suit from the
comics which has the classic purple
helmet with a blue face covering in the
source material his skin was blue but it
looks like it's a soutier that he uses
to travel through the quantum realm
there's apparently a lot of different
looks for kang in the teaser with some
even having his mask off okay so if i'm
understanding this correctly that it is
he himself is not blue but the way he
dons the helmet and the way that
illuminates is all blue yeah okay and
that echoes what a lot of people were
chiming in in the live stream we did too
who must have seen this footage no
better than we do yeah well then
everyone would be like him is he
cree-related
he's could be the same version of kang
or as we've discussed different
iterations of him from different
timelines it's even possible that we saw
this location in ant-man and the wasp
and if janet found refuge here then she
could be used as a way to give some
exposition on kang although that
happened before the events of loki when
the timeline was split time moves
differently in the quantum realm so you
have things happening there after the
end of time which is when the ending of
loki took place lots of timey winey
wibbly wobbly stuff but either way kang
has encountered the avengers before or
at least versions of them in the teaser
scott says to him i don't know who you
are but you made a big mistake i am an
avenger i should have done the accent
for that my might have got cast in the
movie anyway kang replies by saying
you're an avenger i am a conqueror he
also asks if he's killed him before and
he drops this completely nonchalantly
showing that he may have killed an
infinite number of them across an
infinite number
it's pretty wild and it instantly sets
up a threat that's not to be
that's badass
i did hear one thing from this maybe
paul's going to go into it that scott is
like an author or something and they
hinted at that in miss marvel that he
has his own podcast like he's getting a
bit of an ego or he's like trying to
write some type of success or fame he
can't worry about baskin robbins forever
you know so uh with that you know with
that line with you know him saying i'm
an avenger he does have a bit of an ego
and this is going to be a learning
lesson for him as his ass and everyone
ass is going to be getting handed to
them this is the scott lang ego check
movie but with you know gang being like
have i killed you before oh that is so
cool
that is such a cool lie
yeah that's awesome
whereas thanos wiped out trillions of
people with a snap of his finger kang
has conquered countless timelines and in
some instances killed far more than
thanos ever could he wiped out everyone
that ever was and everyone who would
ever be in those timelines and it's all
in his quest for domination now it looks
like he's also going to be joined by the
villain modoc according to rumors on the
film he will be played by corey stoll
who played darren cross in the first
ant-man film you'll probably remember
that he ended up getting stuck in the
quantum realm himself and he likely got
picked up by kang and drafted into his
forces originally in the comics murdoch
was a character called george tarleton
but it looks like they've changed things
up a bit and honestly i think it works
better with the story we don't really
need a big origin breakdown during the
movie if he simply cross so cross that
off your list you stupid [ __ ] his
design has been slightly changed up and
he's now more like a cyborg rather than
being a giant human head i'm not
entirely sure how i feel about modoc
being changed to just a cyborg look who
knows you know there's more looks to
come there's more evolution with the cgi
to happen down the road as it stands
though you know it's like modoc is he
has such a specific look and it is easy
to make him look goofy and it is easy to
laugh at him in non-animated form
there's versions that you could totally
make him like creepy and kind of scary
and people have wanted modock at times
to have his own movie where he's the
standalone villain for that film but you
know if he is coming back
let's i just hope that he actually
serves a true presence and isn't just
there
yeah yeah yeah not to just be like look
another character and i hope that the
redesign is meaningful and isn't like
too far i feel like there's only so much
you can redesign something before it's
not that thing and so yeah while the big
head is a bit out there of an image if
they can bridge the gap or maybe make it
such that he starts out more android and
then becomes you know the modoc that we
know over time or something like that i
think that could be cool yeah
all right other miscellaneous things
that happen or that we see bill murray
at one point taking his glasses off we
don't know which character that he is
and as of now we don't know anything
beyond him seemingly knowing janet now
there are rumors that he's playing
krylov a character who popped up in the
incredible hulk issue 156. krylov was
introduced and killed in the same issue
so there's very little to go off with
him however he did live in the
microverse so yeah he'll likely be
someone who lives in the quantum realm
under kang's command and marvel don't
actually own the rights to use the word
microverse hence the change
oh i would have loved the name
microversamania either way he does seem
to know janet so maybe he was a love
interest with her while she was down
there which would make things a bit
awkward oh damn 30 years a long time
your king's life
never make a pretty woman your wife
don't quote me on that though because i
might be wrong and i just sorry i mean
my uncle judged it off watching the
corner of a video filmed on a phone now
he has glasses on that he takes off and
we could see in the first look that he
looks human so whether it's him or they
did a different design we just don't
know moonlight did something similar to
where they took a very obscure character
in arthur harrow and it just means that
they can really do what they want with
him while still giving a nod to the
comics now murray has kept tight-lipped
about it too and when asked about the
project he said that he doesn't normally
do movies like this but he's simply just
like peyton reed and got on with him
it's a nice reason to join it and
there's also a couple of cute shots that
we get in the trailer these center
around scott reading his own
when he was under house arrest and he's
now become somewhat of a celebrity the
book is titled look out for the little
guy and it'll also complement his
podcast which was brought up during ms
marvel apparently this has turned him
into a bit of a celebrity and instead of
staying a hero he's been out of action
and has focused on this for a while we
actually see him and hope at a premiere
at one point and he's carved out a big
name for himself i got a lot of vibes
watching i mean my uncle got a lot of
vibes watching it and hopefully he has
better luck in the bedroom than to her
own uncle he then gets a call from jail
and after picking it up he's connected
to cassie she's sort of doing what he
used to do and breaking the law but for
the right reasons however he doesn't
want her to waste her life behind bars
like he did he brings up saving the
world again which hank calls him out for
as apparently he always does it now this
has created a gap between the pair
they have a strained relationship due to
his constant need to brag i think
because of that this movie is going to
be about humbling scott on a number of
levels time to make that ego shrink down
too and we're not only going to have his
daughter taking him down a pega 2 but
also kang i really think kang is going
to wipe the floor with him in this movie
and that it'll end on him losing which
will set the villain up as a major
threat scott will probably get a win
against modok but khang has all the
angles covered and can probably beat him
on a number of levels actually yeah you
make a solid point about inclusion of
modok because if they have one villain
they can defeat they're still heroic but
if they lose to king or if king flees or
you know something to do with king
variants of kang but it would be cool if
they did have like at least one
predominant kang that you focus on
throughout phase five and six yeah i
don't know what they're gonna do i trust
jonathan majors with anything that he
does truly wildly amazing actor yeah i'm
excited for this man this is sounding
cool well yeah and then you could have
it be that modoc is like the physical
fight villain for a lot of it and then
kang can be like the intellectual
villain true yeah beating the guy who
saved the entire world wowzer wowza what
a bloody great victory but i think it's
definitely going to set the stage for
how dangerous that kang is i originally
thought the movie might be some goofy
trip through the quantum realm but by
the sounds of it it's gonna be extremely
important the ant-man movies have always
been sort of wild cards in the mcu and
though they're mainly comedies they do
have their big moments and even a lot of
stuff that had big ramifications in
avengers end game it's all building to
kang dynasty and secret wars which we
now know will be directed by destin
daniel crenton anyway from what my uncle
could make out the trailer looks really
good and i am excited to see where they
take things next obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the movie and what
you hope to see in it so make sure you
crap that one what i'm really hoping for
is that if it is gonna be more on the
serious side that it's not a film where
people walk out complaining about the
comedy undercutting the dramatic tension
something that you sometimes often hear
with a marvel movie but that was a great
video paul excellent work seriously
subscribe to this guy he deserves to be
at a million i hope he hits it within
the next month at least
leave a like let's end this with a
flevoleus dorian thank you my buddy it's
uh a marvel video so you know it's your
video john wanted to shout you out i did
i did actually i was gonna suggest if
you didn't say flev if there's anyone at
the patreon who i would want to step
into a modoc like role to you buddy i
just want to see a big flev face with a
bunch of little you know cool gear
around it because i think you would be a
very amusing very fun very colorful
character villain a little kooky a
little quacky but not you know uh far
beyond the reaches of some dastardly
deeds that's you in my eyes phleb you
come across so jovial and kind and
lovely but uh you could do some serious
damn damage i love you
have a good one
[Music]